good morning John so let's start with a
thing that's pretty good about the world
there is a website called Snopes that
got started specifically because the
internet is bad at getting its story
straight and Snopes has been around for
ages letting us reply with a simple URL
when our aunt's sent us pictures of
marbled forks to let them know that yeah
a marbled fork isn't a thing
in fact Snopes has an entire creature
section and usually it is pretty obvious
that like the sea Roach is an
animatronic from Pacific Rim or that
this purple dragon lizard is definitely
fake but other times it gets a little
messy this for example isn't a picture
of a hammerhead salamander because
hammerhead salamanders don't exist but
they did exist 250 million years ago and
that was a sculpture of what they
probably looked like which is in many
ways just as weird and while the bee
hummingbird is the smallest bird this is
not a picture of it this is a miniature
figurine of a chickadee here but for my
money the more interesting thing is when
Snopes has a page for an animal not
because someone made it up but because
no one believes it's real this is
unsurprisingly the case for the Shoebill
stork and the Malabar giant squirrel but
in my humble opinion the most bizarre of
the Snopes creatures that are actually
real is the hammer-headed bat a mega bat
and yes that is the technical term that
isn't just real it's downright common in
West and Central Africa now the term is
mega bat but to be a bat you can't be
that big because you have to fly and you
don't have feathers and feathers are
much better at the flying thing than
thin membranes of skin and so generally
when you see a bat that is very big it's
not as big as it looks it's usually a
strange camera angle bats are good at
being lightweight so while they can have
wing spans of over a meter there is no
bat on earth heavier than three and a
half pounds a hammer-headed bat tops out
at around one pound which is even big
for a mega bat most of which are smaller
than that but look those are all big
four bats the most common bat in North
America for example weighs around a
third of an ounce but none of this is
the thing that astounds you about the
hammer-headed bat right like the thing
that you're looking at is the head like
it's looking kind of dumb now this
certainly isn't the only weird-looking
bat their faces often look pretty silly
but usually that is for better accuracy
of their sonar hammer-headed bats like
other mega bats mostly eat fruit which
are
turi ously sedentary they don't have to
snag them out of the air like bat
sensing bugs so mega bats actually
you're usually pretty cute not so for
this boy this weird face exists as far
as we can tell for one reason and one
reason only the lek lekking is a mating
behavior where a bunch of males gather
in a central location to display out two
females who then pick the male that they
are most interested in that area is
called the lek which yes in my opinion
would be a very good name for a dating
app thank you for asking ever headed
bats display not through visual traits
but through noise that giant rostrum and
the fleshy lips and the split nose all
help them make a big kind of awful noise
that female hammerhead bats which by the
way don't look nearly as weird as the
males apparently find really sexy and
now because we can we're all gonna
listen to that noise together great as
with so many bizarre things in nature
this face that only a nocturnal species
could love comes down to sexual
selection so if I had a chance to
rewrite that Snopes page I would add one
single sentence yes they do look
terrible but get this that weird face
only exists so that they can sound
terrible to John I'll see you on Tuesday
bizarre beasts is a series that I'm
doing on a vlogbrothers I think I only
have a couple more of them left and if
you're subscribed to our pin club you
could be expecting to get the hammer
headed back soon I just got my hand fish
in the mail it's really good I like that
one if you didn't sign up for the
bizarre beast fin Club and you want to
it's you can't I'm sorry we'll try and
figure out something for you in the
future